from screen jumping studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
moving by now your host Andy signor a
little screen jockeys welcome to another
episode of movie sights today is going
to get weird once again I'm so happy to
bring back weird movie fights such as
means we're going to ask a bunch of
topics we would normally not ask because
they're just a lot stranger than typical
but we have some stuff including caps
the event the guardians of the galaxy as
if it was made in the 1980s I know and
in a world where Daniel day-lewis every
Daniel day-lewis role is replaced with
Borat kitchen biz movies would be the
most watchable it's getting a lot of fun
if you want to talk talk along with us
in the conversation you go on twitter at
hashtag movie fights live where dan
Murrow will be there checking the facts
and listening to the comments hey Dan
how's it going hi how are you doing I
have to address the scar in your heads
yeah otherwise everyone will have an
accident I know I'm definitely yeah
that's exactly what happened I'm not an
evil version of myself from an alternate
dimension yes but let's let the guest
guess what happened yes yeah I know a
little household pet accidents but
pretty extreme Wow
blending gained rise so real boring
villain or him is it
it's no good completely normal nothing
paranormal happening with me so it's
best to just move on and not to mention
it at all and my behavior will be not be
different at all so I had to get it out
the beginning to have to kill him if we
needed knowledge I had to address it so
alright but Dan is there to fact-check
today's wonderful guest let's introduce
I'm so happy to have them back you know
I'm hashtag Botanica he's an actor see
them on television all the time regular
on-screen Yogi's it's mr. Mike Carlson
hi okay so here's what happened thank
you thank you everyone
last time we did we were moving fights I
was wearing a giant cockroach outfit and
everyone loved it so I was like what am
I going to top it and I have a giant
tequila outfit in my apartment that I
forgot so we'll add it in post so sorry
yep you could send this up to Lucasfilm
before Saturday and put the tequila
costume on me so yeah anyway I'm out of
here let's aquila costume like an actual
bottle no no no regular tequila not just
checking yeah not the you know okay cool
second he's one of our very own screen
junkies writer of honest trailers it's
mr. Joestar no I
also forgot my tequila costume we both
forgot the same costume so in a way that
kind of worked out well as Latinos
really started me a bummer yeah but
let's light it up I'm so happy to have
this finally gets here you know I'm from
so many amazing comedy shows from mr.
show between two ferns comedy bang bang
which is silver is eighth anniversary
amazing three-hour episode Scott
Aukerman welcome to show
thank you very much which one's my
camera this one all of them this one
right here the one I'm pointing out
right there that is hi everyone I love
it well welcome thanks for having coming
your Scott yeah you haven't played this
show before so I want to make sure you
understand how it goes it's a debate
show but we're going a little weird so
you can go as weird as you like and I'm
basing the the arguments here based on
facts passion creativity so just have
fun with it and you run are you the
judge I am the judge I am i weird Judge
shirt today what would Judge Judy do I'm
done come on I don't know I probably not
hit on our legs and call it raining
correct yeah she definitely wouldn't
what else wouldn't she do she wouldn't
be unreasonable
she wouldn't Sasser bailiff all right
all things I will make sure I don't do
today all right well that's how we play
this game let's get to it with our
wonderful new montage
wobbly night is detained
that sounds like oh yeah so like thank
you Harry Lee for submitting him he made
that himself for us I love that you have
the right soul those we got you know
definitely there's a reason I'm only
pair shoes are you alright this is a
question one another of comedy bang bang
we want to know a very popular podcast
and TV show for podcasts even longer but
we want to ask what movie character
would have the best podcast so take a
familiar movie character we know and
tell us what their podcasts would be for
after the movie during the movie
anything will be acceptable we're start
with you Mike okay so in the last few
months the hottest podcast has been this
missing Richard Simmons where you know
with the Richard Simmons is a fitness
guru who you know was was everywhere
he's this larger-than-life character and
then suddenly he just went missing and
this gentleman who was friends with him
decided to look into it what happened to
him what were the mysterious
circumstances and it's riveting so I'm
going with something similar with a
character who also experienced the loss
of a very famous person somebody who who
you know made such an impact so I'd like
to if I may read the opening of this
podcast before I explain exactly what it
is hi my name is Elliott I guess I never
really believed in aliens when I get
together with friends we always play
cowboys and Indians not space invaders
first moon men I guess it was a pretty
grounded in reality type kid but then
one day everything changed a little
brown alien shaped like a melted dude he
fell from the sky he spoke no English
but we immediately understood each other
we want to adventures in the government
interfered and tortured him like they do
to people overseas anyway
we rescued him and then he went back to
his home planet the goal of this podcast
isn't to drag him back to earth it's to
find out why he left in the first place
this is missing ET the extra-terrestrial
and then hold on there will be a music
cue and I know I can only play like two
second to this
[Music]
so definitely get from et is the answer
is what I'm saying he would have the
best pop kissed miss it oh wow okay
what'd you call again miss not missing
et the extra-terrestrial yes all right
starting strong mic out the gate Joe
what are you doing for your podcast so
there is a very popular podcast that is
hosted by comedian named Marc Maron
where Marc sits down with comedians that
either Marc has really had issues with
in the past or just in his brain had
issues with they hashed those out they
hash out their careers and at the end he
sort of checks in and make sure that
their relationship is still emotionally
healthy it's a it's a really it's a
really fun interesting deep podcast and
I think that a beetlejuice should kill
Marc Maron and then just replace him as
the host of WTF so that's my that's my
pitch Beetlejuice takes over for Marc
Maron on WTF interesting alright well
here more I hope to great stars Scott
where are you going well obviously the
hot you say the hottest podcast is
around is yeah finding Richard Simmons
questionable is that even the title of
its minting resources yeah you know the
title of it obviously the hottest
podcast out there is cereal cereal and s
town everyone knows cereal everyone
knows s town now everyone loves a good
mystery right you know who killed I
confess I've never heard either show but
it's supposedly about murders right so
we need to find someone who's a great
detective right and what movie character
is the greatest detective on screen The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo oh yeah it
was so amazing at detecting things she
had a laptop other things and then it
would start with this song
oh this is a big boy con that has no
relation to the topic so I just want to
play it I mean that's a good talk mm-hmm
so there you go the Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo yeah electronic music is clearly
still okay got it
all right finding out guys we got Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo she's solving
crime of crimes is it one long-form
crime or several crimes you tape each up
into our changes I think it's micro
crimes I think it's like she's solving
micro aggressions by people you know
she'll come in and she'll solve who's at
fault in an argument okay so he's sort
of sort of low stakes really well then
she'll also determine whether one of
those people should be murdered by the
other person yeah and also
microaggressions are not low stakes Mike
Carlton but here's the thing
that one right there mystery guys I was
just in Agra mysteries are passing fad
okay much like guys that like Gilmore
Girls what they're going to go away but
what will never go away in the world of
podcast is an insecure person checking
in with another insecure person to make
sure that their relationship is still
healthy and Beetlejuice can deliver that
in the most entertaining way possible
juice is not an insecure man first of
all first of all I don't condone his
murder of Marc Maron Marc Maron does not
deserve to be mobbed it sounds like you
just want to murder Marc Maron something
about Marc Maron and you wanted to talk
I have against Marc Mero but how amazing
with that podcast episode be with Marc
Maron interviews Beetlejuice o N is like
any cool and beautiful Marino and throws
them to a sandworm of course it does
we're making podcast history when was
the last time a celebrity was murdered
live on the air Andy on a podcast it has
not a happy face book recently but but
no I'm not talking Facebook live I'm
talking I'm talking the world of podcast
mysteries happened on podcast but I'm
going I'm going to give you the the
inciting incident of that mystery live
on the air okay Beetlejuice did not work
the store okay in the 7 in the 70s and
80s he didn't work the door at the kite
doesn't know Mitzi okay he doesn't know
all these comedians he doesn't have the
relationship that Marc Maron does so
when Marc Maron says we good it doesn't
have the way the Beatles you suffer oh
god we good
well here arts what the people that
he knows he knows Lydia he knows what
alec baldwin's character's name was so
first he checks in with them
are we good it's got to be a great great
you're gonna run out a couple very
quickly would Winona Ryder also be on
television she's already said she's
willing to be in the sequel to
Beetlejuice so why wouldn't she also
agree to do beetle juices podcast and
those two have a you could do several
episodes making sure that their dates
Winona Ryder our Lydia it's it's Winona
Ryder and Lydia wait they're two
separate people so we're not a writer
shows well it's I know it is it's audio
so she can be both because you're just
hearing voices so you get even more
guests for your buck so it's like
multi-universe like this different
dimensions is what we're talking about
absolutely she can even be animated
Liana this is very confusing
look I know a good podcast starts with
talent and you you you have it there you
have talent thank you have Beetlejuice
he could probably talk forever he's so
hilarious ya know I've one of the most
hilarious movie characters of all time
yeah but I have to say you say mysteries
will go away and they're a passing fad I
made our Fab mysteries have been around
since - for two thousand years since the
world was created sure but in of in
other forms you know scooby-doo solved
them in an animated cartoon and now
they're in podcast and they're going to
move on to something else whatever the
next big thing is that's where the
mysteries of scooby-doo
if he had a podcast yeah I'd listen to
that I probably be better than all three
of these but we know II have issues with
a lot of different comedians I'm
assuming so yeah that would be
interesting now as far as The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo I want to see yourself
big things I mean I was totally with you
until like I love this song I love the
character but then when it's we're
talking minor stuff I want to see major
I want to see like a six part series on
like some huge horrible murder alright
well if she gets a tattoo every episode
I again I like that she just also has to
deal with a large murder like a giant
murder okay so if we combined could we
do that is that possible by a good
buying podcast is you're constantly
having to up the size of your murder
look this obviously speaks to the
weakness of these pockets if they have
to combine because I was like it would
be may be interesting if Mark Marin was
murdered by Beetlejuice and the girl did
right
tattoo had to solve the murder and that
was a pocket but that's not the ideas
we're dealing with here okay that's open
to a connoisseur episode they're open
okay well here's what I won the final
and the final thoughts here as we go
around I just want to give me a couple
of your guests or just one guest
I don't this is not open er I want to
know I like episode of five over the
chlorine too of course thank you okay
there look this is an adult Elliot
interviewing different people on earth
and ETS home planet of brodo is og which
is Canon if in case we don't know if
there's a book called et the green
planet that was published not long after
the UT movie Elliot's going to be
dealing with people from that planet and
our planet he's going to be dealing he's
going to interview et's teacher a
character named Botanica s-- the wise
and he's going to say hey where's he
been and what's going to happen in
Episode five is you're going to realize
that ETS housekeeper has sort of been
keeping et in the house and that's sort
of like what's going on with ETS
housekeeper and like that's a whole
mystery that will be resolved in episode
6 I want to give away exactly what
happens but that's feel great y'all go
ahead give give it away because I like
to hold on this he just doesn't want to
come out because it's he's been in the
limelight too much so now that pica get
him out no he never comes up he stays
wow so he's into the lure of Reese's
Pieces that is I wanted you to kind and
look these in all right what's your
episode Joe okay so these are our final
thoughts yes okay so I there's one thing
I do want to point out is that podcasts
are supposed to make money they need a
sponsorship what Glen are they if they
don't make money
Mike's intro was so long there's no way
that you fit a plumper Sherri's berries
into that podcast then it was just too
long just too long anyway but let's talk
guess we're going to talk to Casper the
ghost the Friendly Ghost and the cast of
RIPD we're going to talk to these on
daymares own same episode
put them all in a room let's see they're
different undead experiences and let's
let Betelgeuse kid just get in there and
just rip with them so wait the cast of
RIPD Jeff Bridges and right
no no Arabic characters okay theatrical
characters okay Scott final thoughts on
who would you what would your episode
five or six I think that first of all I
would have the cast of RIPD first of all
because there's so much more interesting
than those characters I don't know if
you saw the movie but know what on his
fast but I think I would have actually
Beetlejuice on and I would solve his
murder I would have The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo solve his murder and I
would imagine they it would happen in a
seedy hotel room on a mattress which is
great coordination with the sponsor
Lisa's mattress and that's where we
would make the money so Wow I mean
that's all right Dan yeah closer there
for Scott but yeah anything you'd like
to clean up or any fact-checking AB I
just that s town is currently the number
one podcast on the iTunes charts serials
at number seven so Scott was right those
are two top ten podcast currently where
is missing Richard Simmons with Richard
Simmons is is over so Miss Ouyang done
run pocket number one but it was number
one you guys are successful it was
totally number one for a period okay and
repair aid while I was on it was not it
had to be everybody watching at home
doesn't know who to side with honestly
which is which is good for queer do
advise everyone to commute the
necessarily indignant but sure Deadpool
is the person I saw Tom Rove is this far
is their choice of somebody who has one
that would be to date on it ya know
would you dream too many rapes I also
just googled you would make fun of the
format too much we don't want that yeah
I googled the phrase Beetlejuice cause
of death but I have not yet found
conclusive answers to this a lot we are
like that could be a mystery that that
needs to be soft because I have not yet
found the answer to that a lot of people
when they die in that movie they they
are the form of what they were when they
died so was he a zombie looking guy when
he died I think he was just dressed up
for Halloween maybe as Beetlejuice and
the time traveler yes you look at John
Titor yes all the movie Beetlejuice
loved to dress up as him when I am
traveled back to the yeah exactly I
think he was a member of the stray cats
that died there Brian Setzer group
all right back to the argument you're
all definitely goddamn that's all that
I've got I - yeah did not find a kick
tough but I got a go based on the fact
that Joe and Scott did show a little
weakness there by combining the two
podcast and we said we were open to it
yeah well I think that shows a lot of
vinyl though it's me I've had my
business but the the combo of giving in
to the two and and Mike's immediate
punch down to that and the fact that he
wants you know not micro things the
bigger things and one thing I explained
how confusing peeled juices was which it
was I got to give Mike the first point
so you're on the board in my way but
very good round Scott Joe it was okay
good luck looking at sharing buried
money all right this one comes in from
BSW what bf swaps on Twitter round to
cast the main characters of guardians of
the galaxy
that's star-lord Gamora Drax Groot and
Rocket if it was made in the 80s using
actors popular and working up until 1989
all right Scott you're up first
yeah star-lord yeah funniest main
character of all time of any movie and I
think guardians of the galaxy vol 2 is
going to prove that just so funny you
got to get the funniest actor who's the
funniest actor working in the 80s Kevin
Kline Fish Called Wanda so funny he's so
funny in that he can smell his armpit
you know he has he's shooting the laser
gun amazing he'll do an amazing job love
it
Drax you need some of those big muscles
but you need someone with a sense of
humor most of the guys in the 80s who
have big muscles they have no sense of
humor right you need someone who's
really funny
rowdy roddy piper from they live he's
got the glasses he'd be really funny he
is all out of bubblegum so many quips
and they live groots you need someone
with a deep voice stallone obviously a
group that was the best Stallone
impression you're going to hear all day
was solid again I'm Groot
I wouldn't imagine you're gonna hear
another Stallone impression so I'm
banking on that will be the best one
here all day
as far as Gamora goes you need someone
with experience playing different
colored ladies so at first I was
thinking you know see thomas Howell from
soul man
but he didn't have the cross-dressing
element in that so I'm gonna go with
Femi Taylor from Return of the Jedi
she played the slave girl Lulu and I
think for a rocket you need some sort of
actor with fur so I think stripe from
gremlins is your choice I mean stripe is
there he's got the he's got movie
experience he's got boffo bo already
he's going to bring people into the
theater and this is a combination I
think it's dynamite all these actors uh
you know have maybe never work together
at all you know but I think put them all
in a room and it's going to be
incredible all right look at that Kevin
Kline rowdy roddy piper stallone semi
Taylor and straight from gremlins all
right I'm diggin that Mike it's your
turn tell us who you cast ok star-lord
up first star-lord Chevy Chase the 80s
were the heyday of Chase ok everything
this guy touched turned to gold alright
and if it was guardians of the galaxy
deities more of the same tracks
Drax Andre the Giant we need a wrestler
we need a guy who's funny and we made he
made us laugh we make he made us fall in
love in princess pur I fell in love
while you watched Andre the Giant
indifferences bride he has a gentle soul
about him who did you fall in love with
under the giant the character I mean I
think that's sort of I mean I think
everyone in the room probably agrees me
but I won't be able to ask them until
the show's over I'm Groot we want
somebody who can deliver a very simple
sentence with so much power and I'm
talking about the artist known as Prince
and if you would like if you would
indulge me he would always record sort
of like this and we go I am Groot and he
would sort of turn around like that so
every time and every time yes yeah yeah
only from the side okay Gamora more
Grace Jones made a from the James Bond
movie that I can't recall the name of if
you do a kill if you do a kill thank you
so much rocket rocket Joe Pesci
in a practical rocket suit much like the
Howard the Duck costume there he is look
at that can you imagine how funny and
good that would be so Joe Pesci who did
not break out until 1991 what's
interesting about this is that
this would actually be his breakout
interesting intercept this is the cold a
mechanical someone sawed off Broadway
tonight I'm putting you in a raccoon
what's that that's what's interesting
about some of the listen to his records
okay got to get you into my life heard
there - I've heard his podcast all right
Joe star-lord star-lord
look the 80s weren't about breaking new
actors it was about here's some famous
people and let's make some much let's
just put them in as many vehicles as
possible star-lord Eddie Murphy no one
funnier in the 80s then little sweet
Eddie Murphy funny guy action star
golden child incredibly underrated
action comedy he's got the chops tracks
tracks you go Dolph Lundgren I think we
really solved offs range in masters of
the universe when he played he man and I
think you could really spin that just
sort of dead I'd not quite aware of
where he is in the room delivery into
some comedy and that's what you need
from Drax Group James Earl Jones man
Darth Vader that's your stunt cat anyone
impression like you did I am Groot which
is which is tree for don't choke on your
aspirations one of Darth Vader's
greatest lines Gamora we're going
Janette goldstein Vasquez from aliens
also an actress that has experience in
playing women that are not the color
that she is and also super tough
remember she's doing all those chin-ups
and in a Lane she's super tough she's
super buff finally rocket racoon Bruce
Willis I think Rocket Raccoon now is
perfect and I feel like if you cast
Bruce Willis as rocket you would
basically get the exact same Rocket
Raccoon like same line delivery and all
and in the 80s this guy big comedy guy
moonlighting hilarious Wow all right
well let's here's how I'm going to try
and do this again let's go through each
let's look at some star-lord I'm going
to keep track points on each one so for
star-lord it's Kevin Kline vs. Chevy my
dreams in there oh I think in the 80s
there was no one better as a
communicator than the great communicator
Ronald Reagan I'm changing Ronald Rick
darling are Reagan all right people
loved him in the eighties No
man of the interest all right so we have
Ronald Reagan we have Eddie Murphy and
Chevy Chase now fight that out quick
okay I'm thinking that the Reagan thing
might not work out so well because he
was he was fairly open about losing some
of his marble I don't know you like it
was he was a little unpopular sorta by
the end of his term and he really wasn't
acting very much as far as I can remind
thing every day is an opportunity to put
on some sort of a mask and act hmm
I mean that's true do you think it was
that his last acting role do we think
mortgage has tear down that wall that
was sold that thought it was real life
though that was me doing still owned by
the way no but I mean second best alone
impression of her what do you guys think
Eddie Murphy anymore look and cool he's
so cool no no you know oh my god our
lord is he's relatable like falls down
and he shrugs it off and he's kind of a
dork like oh yeah Eddie Murphy he I
don't know Eddie Murphy goal Jeff fish
out of water in the golden child has a
golden josh is a fail as I was
mentioning the gullet you said Eddie
Murphy in the golden can see the holiday
moving I've ever seen also he's a tiny
man and that's where you get his complex
from that move in this movie that's
where you play the kind just don't fit
him like a banana any tailpipe to the
mini spaceship there's going to be so
many tailpipes in so many spaceships and
let's not lean too close to this weird
spaceship tailpipe hey what about me
chance going to be case cool funny
everyman what against him no think it's
not an act not an action guy again he
wants to make this all about him you
know roll his eyes at the camera with
you son of pratfalls yeah interesting
about this is it would be the start of
chevy chase action career are you too
good for you good for a lot of your
readers are going to be launched I do
want to go back after I'm giving us a
Chevy Chase thing alright Danny we have
a curious even with Scott admitted that
it's not over yet though
did any a news in Ronald Reagan's first
role last website the internet here
ironically is very unreliable like 80s
Internet yes when I come back let us
know
all right so back down tracks under the
Giant versus Dolph Lundgren versus
versus riding by the way I'm changing
mine to Ronald Reagan
I think Ronald Reagan would be amazing
in this road yeah look all right come on
great versus Ronald Reagan Garces Andre
the Giant okay let's all play Ernie's
exactly what you want from Drax he's
this sort of big dumb simpleton that can
just what the smallest twist can become
a very funny comedian is he playing
we're not on the side of Dolph Lundgren
we hated him he was Drago in rock yes we
know you guys cannot keep saying this is
the thing where he breaks out know the
he was not a good guy until the 90s so
he's just quality especially if Ronald
you know if Ronald Reagan is you know is
in here like imagine Dolph Lundgren as
Drax and Ronald Reagan just going at it
because Ronald Reagan plays the villain
in my movie here rocket rate of Reagan
is wha what's the guy's name
I can't remember one the star-lord
Cheerios can explain right Ronald Reagan
would have been in great tracks in the
1960s barn I'll give you that Reagan
would have killed it as very 90s know in
89 I welcome both my presence here
having a great Drex but then president
just took its toll on him and then he
sort of lost that kind of topic I don't
drag his likability
he's a muscle man and we're predisposed
to not liking muscle men but he's got
that sense of humor and you ever message
a tire now he doesn't be a muscle man
he's just old Ronald Reagan Reagan was a
muscle man huh that's not a repackage a
colossal man I don't know what you're
talking about I thought he had a great
body I think Andre
people love Andre too much Andre is you
much Roger Ailes Robert as far as I'm
considered wonders your crew I just want
to hug him dry Andres your Groot I think
you I think you have that whole discount
on my group that's a total middle box I
can't understand so long as Andre the
Giant says a blogger and 80s Batista
haven't a Dolph Lundgren all right look
we got Prince James Earl Jones and
Stallone or I'm kidding I'm changing
mine oh well breaking okay to regulation
James Earl Jones and Prince yeah I mean
here if you guys want to see me do it
again yeah
no thank you oh wait you're still doing
it oh that's just so going we are group
first I'm insulted by Carlton wants to
just limit Prince of all people to three
words exactly if you cast Princeton
something you want to see him go up on
monologue right now you're going to see
him adding my own friends at star-lord
printed material or this is a serious
serious error if you have these up in a
while listen to this and this will
commit to you well I agree
oh I'm doing the clintons on the Reagan
thing but this is the film where Reagan
starts to Clinton some oh that's it
break out break out that is interesting
as I will give it that a reading thing
about it but let's change the rhythm
grid just needs a fun deep voice and you
stunt cast it with Darth Vader because
at this point Laura Bader just being
there damn that wall monster and now
he's a sweet tree that's great that's a
big treat for audience against the James
L Jones he's James Earl Jones I mean you
know he's still a bit away from his
breakout and Field of Dreams as a live
performer and if they were such as a
voice oh no no no III personally I don't
want to go I don't want to watch a
science fiction movie and hear the voice
of a very recognizable science fiction
character that grows right here I really
like doing that to Ronald Reagan but
Reagan gets the point on you know what
urge urge thank you really not to chew
you out
I mean Prince needs more than two lines
and yeah it's two computer than that
Vader meter available all right we got
Gamora Grace Jones Jeanette Vasquez are
we keeping femi Taylor are we going
riding Ronald Reagan I'm gonna you know
what I'm gonna go Ronald Reagan I don't
get really paid off flap you know what
I'm going to go Femi Taylor okay
okay I go ahead really yeah because he
looks just like Gomorrah so why do we
know what she looks like you know we
know she'd be perfect but I don't know
if she's got the chops whereas we know
that Jeanette Goldstein can also put up
a put on a whole lot of body makeup to
play someone of a completely different
skin color what you also hide behind
jobs needed is she actually put on body
makeup yeah for prevention yeah she's
also the foster mom in Terminator 2
right yeah not she's not Vasquez in the
slightest she put on a in contacts and
all that good stuff and then bulked up
she's but she's tough and she can act
she's fun she's charming she's sexy you
gotta want it you never went anywhere
every an alien after alien so that kind
of tells me that the marketplace sort of
viewed her as a no start no she's no
she's a chameleon she disappeared into a
role she I don't know I think if
somebody had been any sort of additive
value to the movie she would have had a
career after aliens I I'm worried I'm
just worried that if Ronald Regan plays
too many roles in the movie this is what
this is this is his breakout in terms of
doing like a nutty professor Klumps kind
of thing can you imagine Ronald Reagan
and Ronald Reagan and Ronald Reagan in
guardians of the galaxy is rich little
there to do any any like a doubling it
is a good run ring home rich little
probably could do some body doubling he
does like that video for toy commercials
and something that was right yeah that
we can get Joe Piscopo involved you know
yeah I gotta give up on a genetic
genetic oh I just wanted to say Piscopo
is also involved in my mouth are Walt
didn't help the fact that you switched
you both switched and help your causes
there the Ronald Reagan was a good
switch previously but not there so Joe
gets that will just wait until the next
ride hippopotamus Anna we got Joe Pesci
Bruce Willis and I imagine
Ronald Reagan Reagan a lock for this
obviously right yes here's out you can't
Ronald Reagan into the studio what is he
just going to say three words no he is
the President of the United States you
want to have him saying more you you
know you never want to leave time on the
table with talent right you're doing a
different voice on this one next to
group so this is his voice foreign will
I am Groot and this is rocket racoon
will I'm rocket racoon as well and he he
always take
pains to make sure that he says in his
lines that he's playing this character
as well are we as Americans in the 80s
prepared to have our president
represented as a small tiny raccoon with
like a lot of size issues that
overcompensates with big guns what are
we saying as Patriots to the rest of the
world and we present the leader of our
country I reckon all right those in
there and kick serious ass which is what
the USA did in the 80s
okay the iran-contra thing you know was
just around the corner so you know we
want to see our president out there
blowing people away with machine gun all
right here a lot of guns what about my
show you look at my problem with this is
that first of all if Reagan were five
feet two it would be perfect how do we
know I'm he was a president and
presidents are tall that's the thing
that we all we elect presidents on
height that's it I mean that's the thing
I'm just saying something that's a fact
so if we're the technology is not there
in the 80s to make a CGI character he's
going to have to play the character like
that Gary Oldman playing a little person
in that movie tiptoes we've all seen
that it's going to look weird Joe Pesci
don't think I'm okay I'm changing mine
to Tim Conway as Dorf Wow okay actually
that's a really good counter regulators
gifts on his knees and you put yours on
his knees so it's a simple sort of phone
call I realize today everyone ordered
those videotape Bradley Cooper is doing
a Bruce Willis impression as rye I would
like to change mine to Ronald Reagan who
was in a horrible accident where he had
like cotton on king of the hill where he
had the shins blown off of him in the
war
okay he's that sigh okay I got to give
us this Scott he committed before
YouTube didn't then you just copy this
bit the whole time and the addition of
Dorf at the end was quite brilliant I
gotta give got the overall point you win
that round I'm glad no one to our
garnish or the guy is going to be all
Ronald Reagan except for rocket who will
be Tim Conway historic tour classic
right Dan yes sorry I had to make that
no court no Ronald Reagan was six foot
one inch tall so he was his fall guy
yeah horsey is his last acting role was
in a 1965 episode of a TV show called
Death Valley days his last movie was in
1964 it was called The Killers Joe Pesci
he never like did some other weird
little cameo he did like a one episode
of Disney World for love Disney as
himself got it like he wanted I know it
was murder I'm thinking about it again
whose mother my older girls enemy Pesci
was deadly weapon two in 1989 he done
Raging Bull 1980 and let's not forget of
course about his role as mr. big and
Michael Jackson's Moonraker court was a
key dream for me I loved that of all the
reasons that were brought up against
Scotts Ronald Reagan choice that nobody
brought up the fact that him being the
sitting president might be a little bit
I know an opportunity I said there might
be a problem with that there are some
clear some issues so whenever a Reagan
offensive was solid would you like to
see Trump star in a movie like mad dear
I think that I'm not far off I think I
could have a Nike day all right round
three we want to know what two movie
characters from any franchise should get
a spin-off movie where they solve
mysteries they can pick any two from any
movie Mike your first alright when I'm
thinking about a classic detective team
I want a good cop bad cop situation I
want two characters that are way
different so yeah you're all probably
thinking like oh you probably all had
two names that popped in your head when
this question came up and I'm probably
just going to say the names we're all
thinking of dr. Manhattan from Watchmen
and Tom Hanks is Sully from the movie
Sully yeah Matt is exactly what I was
not thinking welcome you were in have a
more interesting brain obviously but
look we want a guy who's out front who's
personable a guy who talks agai who can
think on his feet
alright this is a guy who under
incredible pressure was able to land a
plane on the Hudson okay
this guy can do anything if you can do
that in dr. Manhattan we have a person
that can just do anything he literally
can space-time matter you can do all of
it you can call it control all of it and
I think on a detective too
name someone who can control all of
space and time pretty helpful
alright question but we'll come back to
them Joe I think the most important
thing is I went from a mystery team are
someone who's a little funny or not
necessarily a whacky comedian but
someone who kind of is always kind of
taken the piss out of what's going on
and then someone who's very very serious
to sort of counter them and stop all
your tomfoolery and so from that I want
Marge Gunderson from Fargo and the
talking Velociraptor from Jurassic Park
three now Marge Gunderson you know very
light-hearted he doesn't take life too
seriously she's fun she's got that voice
she's always kind of surprised by
everything and then you have the
incredibly serious talking rafter from
Jurassic Park 3 who doesn't have time
for her quaint nonsense sometimes you
know oh we have a mystery to solve Marge
Gunderson and she's like Oh get to it
you bet and I just did the chemistry for
these two would be absolutely off the
chart plus one is a talking Raptor all
right Scott well I have to say that I
enjoyed your answers and you almost had
it you almost got it right but I think
the the two clear choices when you're
talking what we want in a buddy comedy
is comedy and to that end I would say
Woody Allen from Manhattan and Scully
from Monsters Inc you almost had it with
dr. Manhattan in Sully but I think is
Woody Allen in Manhattan and Scully from
monster's name is Sully Sully crew yeah
and that's what that's the interesting
part that people don't know is there is
a you saw monsters University obviously
where he came in his name was solely
yeah he changed it from Scully oh
they're not going oh yeah yeah because I
was a huge exiled fan I just also want
to say like he's talking about the
funniest movie there's nothing in this
question that indicates comedy my movie
would be very very good comedy how weird
okay I do hate coming I do you don't
like comedy in movies in movies I would
prefer that it stayed out of it yeah so
your your movie is going to be deadly
serious with no comic relief no not
really yeah
I don't get enough I don't think dr.
Manhattan and Sully could solve a
mystery because just there's just so
much blue dong front and center at all
times in that duo that I just think it
would get distracting exactly meanwhile
green dong with Sully and Scully aka you
know it's great in a movie because it's
tiny Yali is the blue one care fluid
Sully is the furry little blue one so
there's a blue one at comfort right now
that's what I'm that's why I'm changing
to Mike was a scar yeah yeah okay like
crystal Michael crystal yeah yeah okay
yeah Mike Wazowski Woody Allen okay I
also I also feel that Sulley Tom Hanks's
Sully does not need a mystery partner
this is a man that can do almost
anything he sets his mind to he landed a
plane in the Hudson for God's sake he
does the mystery of airspace you know
why would he department need a partner
again it's wasted real estate I think
I'm going to change mine to Mike
Wazowski and Sullivan sir thank you
they're a great team like there's not
Sully from Sully no no not at all Sully
although I love that movie yeah I would
watch that movie too and I feel like I
did see if I see I've seen a layers of
my Monsters Inc okay yeah attacking
monsters but as a hardier they're
solving mysteries
they're solving no no time they're
basically inventing doors that causes
little boys and girls to scream I want
to talk about a great cop in March
Gunderson and a very wise talking Raptor
that is very smart he can open doors
according to the Raptor line playing
okay here's the thing the Raptor talks
in Allen Grant's like nightmares where
he has been a plane or did they never
really heard him say that he wakes up he
goes because the Raptor goes alland and
then it hangs up here comes Allen and as
a foreshadowing but like this Raptor is
actually just a manifestation of Allen
Sookie the only real skills he has are
torturing
sam neill from Jurassic Park welcome all
that ilk raptor this Raptor only takes
place in the dreamscape and how much
help I am going to be look if you're
going to give me astral plane Raptor
thank you for this gift that's even
cooler here after all he gets
talking Raptor all the same cool stuff
from dr. strange Marge yeah
Inferno is going to be on her own during
the day and only get the Raptors help at
night when she dreaming no no it's
always night I know right we're doing
stuff like having sex with Samuels
girlfriend from high school stuff to
torture Samuels Karen oh no no you can't
do anything other than a haunts Sam
Neil's dream this is a raptor that's
focused on solving mysteries and that's
it look how are you something I need how
are you solving you address that problem
how if he doesn't seem to exist
to haunt sam neill Marge Gunderson is a
great cop and this is a velociraptor
that can tuck it's clearly there are
other people like other people are going
after streams are we in the dream world
not a ghost Raptor Andy this is the
talking rap goes attractor at that point
Carlson pitched my ghost rafters no this
Raptor goes radical raptor Raptors
reptilian all Raptors have a very short
lifespan okay and so that Raptor would
be dead by now so it is a ghost Raptor
look will you help me that have to last
for Liars can I make an important point
about my movie dr. Manhattan is so good
at solving mysteries he can solve them
in five seconds my movie is going to
have five seconds long your movie is
going to be five seconds long way it
seemed always a five-second movie that
did almost got wait he solves over 500
mysteries in one movie
we've never solved that many mysteries
in a single it's really just one mr.
it's not boring Sully's doing another
dr. Tolley is telling us about the time
he landed a plane on the Hudson Andy
dr. meanwhile new instruments let me
tell you what dr. Manhattan can't solve
a mystery because he's too sad and
brooding he's just got to sit on Mars
and play with his big old blue dong and
do it oh boy I feel sorry for me he
doesn't have time to solve mysteries
he's too sad I think my movie it's
proven there's two movies out there
already that are huge box-office hits
starring these characters and the public
loves them these are two characters
trained in scaring not solving mysteries
exactly Marge Gunderson go get him Cobb
they said Oh Reb miss Joey Buscemi being
the villain at the end of Monsters Inc
so I think they can do I thought I would
like that last remark stricken from the
record all right hand careful are we
supposed to be keeping a record of
Trigon
the matter for me knew I was like
fact-checking I was like a velociraptor
7 estimated like 15 20 years but like
what's the point really react on that
Jackie Manheim on Twitter summed it up
perfectly what he said there are no
right answers on weird will be fights
just more questions not as long as a
parody from very true and it's very true
oh this one's rough why sullying their
protector right now to tell the story
about some okay wavelets and then yeah i
got stuck with my marvel margin but the
raptor I'm so confused is he in the
dreams but your scenes and I and we have
no idea if he says anything else other
than on yeah yeah we know you look only
so getting room everyone loves them very
helpful way heard earlier yeah name is
he was only there and it can only say
Alan I might have been fascinated but
you didn't you didn't go there and then
we have us a hatchet job we have Mike
and Sully from monsters inc who pretty
much already done that already drawn
that yeah oh man this one's tough I
guess I want to learn more about the
Raptor and so our answers can finally be
heard that's a well know whether it's a
dream or not
so Mike gets the point because 500
mysteries in one movie that's really
calm thank you yeah
really love you I agree without you're
just about thank you I didn't know what
I was talking about now
time for round four this comes in from
Johnson's on Twitter in a world where
every Daniel day-lewis role is replaced
with Sacha Baron Cohen's Borat which of
his movies would be most watchable
that's right
replace one of Daniel day-lewis his
iconic roles with Borat
Joe your first there's only one of Dana
day-lewis's movies that could be made
more watchable with Borat and that's
Lincoln what a bore that movie was his
his Lincoln character was so oh he
talked so long and drawn-out he just
wasn't just wasn't fun and you know when
you're when you're watching a heroic US
president try to abolish slavery you
don't want it to be a bummer you want it
to be fun you want to really cheer for
the guy
and so that's why Borat as Abe Lincoln
will be the most fun just think of how
many fun Borat things he's going to say
about the Hat and never telling a lie
and growing up in a cabin Borat is
Lincoln
alright Scott which shot Daniel
day-lewis movie are you pickin look
we've all been trapped next to a
co-worker a family member who just saw
Borat thinks it's really funny and trots
out of Borat impression right that's a
little bit we hate it
alright we wish that movie had never
been made all right I think the world
would be a better place if Sacha Baron
Cohen had been shot in the head as a
baby and Borat had never been made we
all agreed we all can agree with that
and that's what a lot of people are
saying so I think there's only one movie
where we don't have to hear that voice
for a good chunk of the movie which is
there will be blood all right
totally silent film for a good 2530
minutes of that film we're not hearing
the Borat impression we're just seeing
him dig around in the dirt he's being
totally silent he's not bothering anyone
sure yeah at a certain point in he
starts talking to people as I drink your
milkshake and everything you know and
we're like okay I'm I'm ready for the
movie to wrap it up but for the first 20
minutes pure silence and silence is
golden in this case okay
this question is what movie would make
the most sense if a Kazakh standing man
named Borat
most most watchable so already yours
you're off on the wrong foot look it's
hard to come up with the answer this
very fact because sometimes you have
commercial audition or something anyway
how did you do did you get it first call
there's no way to know good luck
thank you what was what was the product
pet food
cool tiny theatrical representation if
anyone out there could help me out do
you have a showcase come up the people
could see like a lava lamp I am renting
oh do you have children re in theatres
on Hyperion and I'm going to put up a
one-man show oh god I would pay to see
that please do that okay I'll do it
right back to the urgent I'll bring
Scotts manager please if you would
I'm dying out here in a world where
every Daniel day-lewis roles plays wave
Sacha Baron Cohen's Borat which one
would make the most sense watchable Last
of the Mohicans okay why because it
makes the most sense okay
for s this this movie is about a man who
is not one of the Native Americans who
was raised by them so when they stumble
upon Borat and these Native Americans
they think oh a man from Kazakhstan came
here and he was raised by these people
you know it makes total sense and thus
makes the movie more watchable because
it makes sense
alright put it out guys well first of
all Lincoln has so many fun catchphrases
in the movie Lincoln that I think Borat
could really adopt and make his own
catchphrase is like buzzards guts man
buzz it's cus great success I just like
the lines already line up or I wouldn't
you wouldn't even have to put a whole
lot of Borat lines into Lincoln you just
take the lines that Lincoln already says
and say them in a Borat voice well you
wouldn't know the different what makes
Lincoln great the fact he doesn't have a
mustache what makes Borat great he has a
mustache okay close I mean out of the
running here you shave off boretz
mustache he's Bruno
hmm I'll say this it's gonna be a little
weird when are to be there just hurry up
that Island tell you about Millers
jointer I'll say it's sad to see Joe go
first of all because he father goes on I
think it's about vodka Wow
I just want to say that it doesn't make
any sense with their bow be blood
because he's not that he has his he
adopts a son boy doesn't adopt a son in
the movie Borat that's not a thing you
would do
did he wait we're parsing here what
Borat would do because I don't think
Bohr had character logic and Maura would
be kicked out of the Mohican tribe
within one hour every place Borat when
he was knocked out not if he was raised
from the time he was a young boy he
would have been actually the character
would be different in mind because you
would have different manners so he's not
more at so he absolutely the name is
Borat he's his Ramos Horta but he
doesn't act like borign I don't want to
go see you Boram okay where's my acting
like I mean how does it gimme a look as
I heard the milkshake what will happen
in yours the spirit runs through all of
us either I think you knocked yourself
out I gotta agree on that but I got out
alright let's take a good clean round
stating bad force not kidding me alright
well actually sir I'm gonna add the
Konitz round ready because why not
that's a quick one rookie Joe can you
get a point on the board huh
probably not you know any points all
right we're going to the last round here
we are tied Mike and Scott each have to
Joe you don't have any sadly but I'm
gonna make this interesting for round
five I'm going to make this worth two
points because it's weird why not I
don't care I'm allowed ocula so this is
ground five question is make a drama
better by adding a montage scene scene
to smash mouth all-star
you all know how that goes right you got
it make it better because one scene in
there has to have a montage someone was
having that montage where the song Smash
Mouth Smash Mouth all-star somebody what
you know we all know that song alright
who's ready
I could use more more time no more
viewing in yeah what somebody once told
me the world is not a row me I ain't the
sharpest tool in the shed she was
looking kind of dumb with her finger
shape of an L on her forehead well
they're coming and they don't stop
coming back to the hill we have to know
ladies magic we did it so terribly we
know I'd be Pink's man every day for
giving us that we I guess this way
except with November rain a lot so I get
Mike we remember swell I okay again look
blue velvet senate's hoppers character
Frank booth is one of the most
terrifying on-screen villains of all
time he's he's twisted he's crazy he's
like an insane sexual predator he's
abusive he says stuff like my me and
like my baby wants to F I don't want to
say it I want to be dirty it's
horrifying so let's take that movie
which is so disturbing already and let's
put in a scene that is so crazy and out
of place and even more disturbing set to
smash mouths all start a scene where he
has the oxygen mask he's wheezing he's
talking about having sex with mommy he's
abusing women but it is also exactly the
same scene as the music video for
all-star which was from the movie
Mystery Men that's going to be so
strange people are going to go this
movie is really taking in taking such
artistic license and liberties that this
David Lynch is a genius he I would never
expect something so jarring in a movie
like this this movie is the greatest
movie of all time said that hypothetical
person watching it is he's seeing it
with the master singing along with her
yes with the mask and then he puts in
like mommy and boy look what's happening
during the montage aspects of the well
because I worried yeah integral part of
this I watched the music video for
all-star right before this it's from the
movie mystery man and
has like Dane Cook and stuff auditioning
to be mystery man while the mystery men
sit around and go hmm
so Dennis Hopper is also auditioning to
be a mystery man
so he's adjusting for mystery men not
Bluebell correct yes in the middle of
blue velvet in the middle of the moon
with the mask on yes but I met him on
the song he's singing the song sometimes
but then they'll something like oh wait
I am just jerking off or something or
just like hitting someone okay gentle
Andy you knew we'd come back to this yes
you guys know what a real bummer was the
second world war and that's why first
one right on the money first one was you
know had its ups and downs but overall
good time Second World War
that's why I'm putting a montage to
all-star in Saving Private Ryan this
montage comes in they found Private Ryan
they've made the decision that they're
all going to stay and defend this little
bit of town but you know there's there's
a great montage where they're all
getting their gear ready and they're
they're learning how to make sticky
bombs and figuring out where they're
going to place their snipers and you put
all star to that because this movie has
been such an emotional slog that you
really need a little bit of an uplifting
you need a little smash mouth before you
get punched in the gut again as the
final battle in sequences of this movie
take place you really need some
smashmouth time with these characters to
really love and appreciate them before
that horrifying final battle happens all
right in Pratt one jello is definitely
better than the talking dog thank you
last time I tried to put a talking dog
in the Saving Private Ryan and I got it
thank you Scott are you hiring
and it weird yeah and you have kids yes
I want you just turned five today just
for fun yeah perfect perfect for this
question what's the hardest thing to get
your child to do cool I'll just answer
it for you go to the Opera that's what I
was going to say it's so tough to get
our kids to go to the Opera I how many
times have you heard this dad dad I
don't want to go to the Opera today look
kids hate opera people of all ages hate
opera we I don't even know why it's
still a thing right no so what but
what's one of the greatest montages in
cinema history
The Godfather killing the heads of the
five families but the tag leas mo green
shooting him right in the eye but what's
the biggest problem with that montage
opera that thing that we all hate and
say turn it off turn this movie off I
don't want to see The Godfather any more
how many times is your son said that all
the time so my pitch is let's get rid of
that stupid opera put in all star watch
mo green being shot through the glasses
to that hey man you're an ulcer blood
coming out of the glasses okay then I'm
on board I'm ready to watch
Al Pacino shut the door on Diane Keaton
I'm rotting in until the end at that
point all right Wow who is the all-star
in each of yours songs who is it
reflecting upon could you help me there
Frank
booth is a perverted all-star okay Oh
Tom Hanks absolutely is is is definitely
the from beginning to end of this movie
is an all-star that gets his game on -
Tom Hanks as Sully you got it in
magoffin they're talking about because I
need to live it up like is point of
clarification have you have you were
just replacing out for music or have the
people that got went to see the Opera
are they now watching smash there
watching Smash Mouth much like in the
movie rat race and we have to change the
editing a little bit obviously because
the song is different so we're just kind
of like you know changing up the style
making a little more like MTV at it
a little more fast-paced you know and I
think you know the movie has been pretty
slow at that point it's a three hour
movie you don't think that those upbeats
of all-star really fit the the carnage
of that last scene in Godfather I
disagree I think people watch this movie
and they're depressed at the end of it
they look at Michael Corleone has
changed into essentially a monster and
they want to leave you know feeling good
about themselves I'll tell you what
doesn't fit is in a movie blue velvet
it has a wonderful wonderful song in it
already in dreams as lip-synched by Dean
Stockwell
I knew every year you want to put
another musical number into that film
it's going to the well once too often
because auditioning for Mystery Men is
not a montage it is a brief scene and
the monty should be in you really wanted
to be metatextual about this he should
be auditioning for the movie blue velvet
I think it's a bunch of mystical has the
cast of Mystery Men in it sure I'm
really the only one giving you all star
and it's giving you a purpose that
serves the narrative of the film and
dramatic pictures everything should
serve the narrative and I think all star
inserted at that emotional crux in
Saving Private Ryan that breath the calm
before the storm that last breath before
everything goes to hell that's where you
want to get your game on and go play
Andy let me ask you a question hmm
I'm going to give you three filmmakers
Francis Ford Coppola Steven Spielberg
David Lynch of all of them who would be
the best at integrating a totally out of
place Smash Mouth song montage into
their movie Steven Spielberg obviously
Coppola here because look at one from
the heartland look at one from the heart
one of the best movie musicals of all
time
he knows his way around music Steven
Spielberg is such a huge world war two
buff and just listen to the lyrics of
the song somebody once told me the world
is going to roll me and indeed it did I
ain't the sharpest tool in the shed
RG eyes were brought in from from all
walks of life and it was you know you
might be super-smart you might not be
the sharpest tool in the shed but we're
all brothers here in the trenches we're
going to step up and do something heroic
and that's what all stars about that's
what I think the world war since World
War two if Andrew Jackson had been
I mean why world war two you know he
could have figured that out but it's not
but so so okay Dan
think I heard enough there yeah dan I
think that I just as an added fact check
but it I was just looking at the
official Smash Mouth video on Revelation
restaurants VEVO for all-star given that
me a unique opportunity here because
it's eight hundred thousand views away
under a hundred thousand views away from
hitting a hundred billion a lot I think
screen junkies I think we should be I
think we collectively as a community
should should put this so hashtag it
over go to these Smash Mouth once I
found our hashtag screen joke junkies
did it chunky hash tag screen of this
man junkies hashtags great joke you did
it go and let's get let's actually
community let's put our overall you guys
don't got it some like you thank you
great clearancing of those hashtags also
you just use of your audience should be
like maybe on your own things really
wanting a magical fight but follow your
Twitter account yeah how about can we
haven't think they should have done the
Shrek honest trailer because they should
have I think we could do that I was
going to do it what everyone if you feel
that I'm wise that we could we could we
could help them out history yes we could
make history alright well if you feel
like helping Smash Mouth there you go I
selected I have nothing over here to
occupy my time maybe I have something
PayPal the Twitter yet but people could
mail letters to Ari Emanuel on my behalf
to get me some theatrical representation
I really appreciate it I help screencast
attack
I did it Mike hashtag my qunari
all right I can't believe I'm doing it
but just our man you got the point
thank you that man was allowed to me
that made a lot of sense and you got a
bull win on crime right that makes it a
tie I'm glad we get given two points
really two points so that's two you two
Wow that means I got to do a three-way
tie breaker
oh you're one of them see how I'm gonna
pull this and then winner of this will
go on okay here we go play with it on a
thinker this is a sinker and I'm gonna
clued all three of you in this because I
think it's either on or nowhere it was
gonna be a speed round but so you all
have to be quick but I think ways it's
not around where there's a lot of time
and we just speak quickly you have 20
seconds to answer and then 10 seconds
all up got it I make you a little bit
more but here it is all right I'll
probably get it for a minute you're
going to need to think about this so as
soon as you got a good answer spit it
out that way you can lock it in so we're
not taking two okay you'll all go
whoever speaks their answer first will
be the dictate to order here right now
which Best Picture winner should have
the toilet scene from dumb and dumber
added to it and why Oliver hold on great
we have Oliver let's let them pick crash
avatar not avatar mount of his picture
winner can I still debate for it judges
No okay I'll allow it
Titanic okay Titanic mm-hmm have
entirely the avatar of Shiva new visa
okay
Scott you'll have 20 seconds a time will
begin when speaking and you're doing
when your time is up go ahead when
you're ready look musicals they're
boring what would make a musical funny
we've seen sausage party where they're
having a sex songs and everything I
think put in a toilet and fart sounds
are really funny and put those in a song
and Oliver Oliver I mean super super
funny right there Bill Sikes you know
like I've always wondered does he go to
the bathroom every scene I watching that
I wonder Joe Oliver I think you
completely ruined the timing of the
songs with those toilets crash is
already an i unwatchable movie
I think toilets would say
crash from itself just a lot of scenes
or someone had too much laxatives and
they have to poop
that's what bridges all the characters
together they all use the same toilet
when they when they have to have their
little poop explosions Mike a lot of
people don't know that Titanic there
were a lot of other disasters going on
the ship and they had to cut them from
the movie for time but there was a whole
outbreak of food poisoning on the ship
and there were multiple people that had
to make very gross bowel movements so if
you put that into Titanic in a longer
cut you're going to see oh my god this
is even more of a tragedy than I thought
it was to begin with and that's going to
really hit home with people about what a
national nightmare alright here's what
I'm going to do in this I'm going to put
Mike through Mike you're in first thank
you Joe and Scott now you'll get ten
more seconds to tell me why Oliver or
crash is better here and that will
define who gets to join him in a speed
round okay so you have ten more suppose
I get 15 seconds this because it's uh
okay go ahead Scott what everybody well
look Oliver you have the artful dodger
okay and when I think of The Artful
Dodger I think about him
the one thing he can't dodge is the fact
that everyone poops everybody poops
and I think that humanizes the character
and alright Joe last megohm count
everybody does poop and I think that's
the point crash was trying to make but
it didn't do it well so I think if the
movie like crash really wanted to solve
racism you really drive that point home
we all crap in the same toilets no
matter what color our skin is when we
have too much laxatives we all poop a
lot and that how much laxatives are you
eating that is just enough oh I think
you know okay what do you think on that
one I'm a double sister Wow keep on
relax
I mean don't do them I see Joe's overall
point I do like the kind of existential
thing though of the one thing the artful
dodger yeah I got me to do is nature so
I'm going to go with making substantial
ism over concept here but it's very
close yes it was very close to me too
but I got to give it to Scott there
Scott you get those second piece but Joe
fabulous show thank you now you get to
help me judge who wins
okay we have five more tokens like
survivor the people who get voted out
now get that down oh I should have been
nice yeah alright we this time now we
have five speedrun questions it will be
the same format so speak up quickly when
you have your answer whoever says it
first will get that answer if you don't
say first you'll have to pick another
answer you'll have 20 seconds and then
10 second rebuttal any questions before
we begin
I was a contracted time doesn't start
until you start talking yes you can take
a second if they need it here we go
but first time I speak out your answers
you get it what movie character would
you want to sit next to you on an
international flight Sully Sully from
monsters ink that's the John Goodman
okay yeah yeah alright Scott's up first
with Sully
time begins when you begin speaking
obviously if this plane goes down who
you gonna call I took hold another
famous movie not the ghostbusters you're
gonna call Sully to get in there roll up
his sleeves and take care of business
the way that Sully does obviously you
need him yeah got him right there all
right Mike Sully from monsters Inc is a
great conversationalist he's affable
he's nice he's somebody who you could
hold a conversation with for hours and
hours at a time
this fella he's not even flying the
plane and I'll be honest with you he
prattles on a lot about this plane
landing as far as on the Hudson he's
always talking about it that's going to
get annoying after a while and Sully
he's just going to talk about different
stuff going to college scaring little
girls he's got a whole bunch of things
he's done that alright ten seconds he's
tubed solely for Monsters Inc it's too
big he's like bigger than Kevin Smith
okay he's gonna he's gonna need that
seat belt extender he's never going to
get the opportunity to sit next to
anyone on a plane because I'm gonna have
to buy two seats intersect this is a
first-class flight okay so there's a lot
of room and it's not an international
flight which means there's actually more
room in the aisles so that's perfect and
here's the thing if something goes down
they can go into the dream universe with
the door that's perfect that will save
you obviously my opponent has never been
on a first-class
like in his life alright the
International time is up wow that was a
great back and forth I am I have to be
honest I did take there's any coming
back from Mike's point about Sully's the
monster being a great conversationalist
as a boring husband story until but the
idea of myself I spend my Silva
situations jammed into a seat next to
Sully from us been good collect for me
so I got to Scott joke that really did
pay effect here I just felt a parole and
we're gonna yeah I got give us oh yeah
that wasn't really what you both had it
and then he hit at the end of Scott gets
the first point pretty good fight fight
of the night maybe yeah I was getting
all right of the night number two got
another thing I guess is now it had you
that if you number two if you could
portal into any celebrities head Allah
being lon Being John Malkovich who would
you choose a celebrity or a character a
celebrity a celebrity you've got it
like John Malkovich would you choose
Robert Duvall
John Holmes hmm all right okay Mike your
person she spits pokers look I like a
peaceful easy type of living okay I'm a
simple guy from a simple place
Schaumburg Illinois
I don't know Robert Duvall's brain it's
probably very simple he likes to eat
he likes to clear brush he likes to go
help his cattle and he likes a nice meal
he likes to go to bed this is going to
be a peaceful time hanging out in mr.
Robert Duvall's brain sounds like a
perfect vacation to Michael I'm talking
about my third person John home sir look
most like my opponent I could mention my
hometown Cypress California and get
sympathy points about the fact that I
came from a place but instead I prefer
to focus on the argument which is John
Holmes he's had the life that we all
have wanted to have having sex with
thousands of women and dying of HIV two
extremes the first part of that sounds
good I'll be honest the second part the
long battle with HIV sounds you less
good I like that Duval Duval has not at
HIV as far as I can all right
ten seconds for Scott Duval it has the V
covered you have to admit that in his
last name I know you not a Sgt I guess
so good so you admit that so already
you've shown weakness and I think this
is over all right show based on those
arguments that was tough
mad that well was it yeah the you know I
already kind of dig the idea of the
quiet cowboy life before Eddie Ross
boyhood Bronco and I don't know that HIV
was an uphill battle man I know it is
for a lot of people and you should
really laughing
I donate to charities and benefits and
research I'm a weird choice I do it with
it and I got to go divulge are you agree
okay we're tied up three three here we
go next up oh you really live in Rio and
I don't know my name that's what I'm
saying huh you have to is going in it
didn't get it more you didn't get that
point so hydrate your point doesn't
material oh all right
move in honor of comedy bang bang one of
my idols what movie would you want to
replace the soundtrack with composed
completely by Weird Al take a conviction
soundtrack out and compose a completely
new one all by where now which movie
would you do that to a hard day's night
Sweeney Todd whoa Jesus all right I want
to watch both of those here we go you're
at first a hard day's night is a great
film but let's be honest the Beatles
music takes away from the story and the
characters so we need to have something
that what juxtaposed with the Veals so
I'm talking about weird out let's let's
put in Yoda let's put in the Phantom
Menace song that he did stuff that
you're going to go hmm this isn't going
to distract me from looking at Paul's
dreamy eyes or ringo's cool haircut this
is going to make you really look sweetie
Todd great film but sometimes music is
inaccessible you know I mean he's never
going to have the hit student Andrew
Lloyd Webber has I'm just imagining a
movie where instead instead of
greenfinch and Linnet bird it's
greenfinch and Linnet nerd okay and he
gets on that scooter on that Segway and
another smash hit the songs and Sweeney
Todd correspond to what actually is
going on the songs and hard day's night
er sort of it's like well what was on
Abbey lap Beatles album we release so it
would actually make more sense to sub
songs about Yoda or what happens to
little Anakin Skywalker I think that
you're describing a perfect movie a hard
day's night and you're trying to polish
the opposite of a turd which I'm not
sure exactly what the opposite is I
guess the opposite would be a P is like
a stream of PE you're trying to polish
it P it's impossible all right
yeah well Scott gummies can Scott them
at least did parrot he did know some
clever parodies of the swing time you
didn't a best of album and hardest right
so I could be a one Beatles songs a I
don't know I've never really every
Beatles I have to expect the ambition of
successfully we're Dowling a song from
Sweeney Todd so yes I also have to agree
I don't know we can make up original
notes alright some of the best I'm going
to Minnesota just an honor the biggest
ball time I had never thought about it
really before but you can't polish the
stream of pee and I'm going to watch it
later yeah a bedroom I'm gonna walk away
from today with that in my heart I gotta
go Scott on this you could polish things
with a stream of pee but yeah not the
other way around
alright Scott gets the point here we go
so Mike you need to get this one yes yes
yes
what movie characters should become one
of the sharks on shark tank I think
Oscar from Shark Tale what's that
what's shark a which outrun blaster
other women oh yeah you don't know
sharks and I don't now you remind me
Willy Wonka Wow
Oscar from Shark Tale and Willy Wonka
all right it's got your first I realized
I have an uphill battle because you
don't know the film but let me tell you
a little bit about it Oscar is a small
fish who dreams of being a big fish and
to do that he lies about killing a shark
played by Jack Black I'd remember he
fits in with sharks sharks are his best
friends this is a character that is
going to fit in well on Shark Tank and
deal with the other sharks in a great
way and quite honestly in a funny way
Mike I believe that we're talking Shark
Tank of TV shows so this is these are
not literal sharks we want a real
business owner somebody who actually has
experience like dealing with a company
and running it in hiring employees
somebody who knows a great product like
an Everlasting Gobstopper or you know
runs runs are a great product and the
Willy Wonka is going to sit on that
council and he's going to make a lot of
good decisions that's what I know when's
the last time you watched Shark Tank
never yes it starred real sharks would
you watch it
no of course you would because that
would be awesome
he's he's looking something up to the
Yoda time ty here we go uh I believe
Scott wrote the movie short tale I
additional dialogue look if people were
to size of Eva beans because of this
would that be so bad I have to go to
death right anyway the area I just had
to make sure though just for pulling
that off in time I thought to keep that
to Mike and let's Joe or Dan what do you
think Mason's argument that was a pretty
pretty good pull I have to say III Scott
had me a no pun intended hook line and
sinker and no Mike kind of happen we
could have used you realize we were
writing quite honestly you know that the
counter I was looking for was as if this
actually mattered
boy is that Willy Wonka clearly he's not
interested in running this is that's
kind of was looking for extreme at well
although this is a younger one looking
at someone actually kind of fun but I
got you this an alkalizing yeah everyone
go the Phantom won't like young Sheldon
I fact that I go deep enough my prep to
know that before even said it gives Mike
the point so making you look that good
for to for here we go this is it okay
which Oscar nominee director should take
over the Smurfs franchise Oscar nominees
the nominees are nominated or winning
all except either well currently because
if neither Rama
I mean James Cameron Wow James Cameron
Smurfs okay Scott
when are we ready let me know I have to
say mr. act me is this gamesmanship
right I think it looks like it's settled
okay hi really free go this weird that
it was very strange uh I have to say
I'll say Martin Scorsese Wow okay we got
hardened Scorsese and Jim cheek James
Jim I know me
Jimmy cameras out at Jim Cameron Smurfs
here we go your first mic ok Smurfs we
needed to be a crowd-pleasing family
film that's one of the biggest hits of
all time and that's all that James
Cameron does he makes the biggest hit
and most importantly James Cameron takes
a bunch of blue characters that no one
cares about any spoons shed into gold
we know that's one of his top things
that he does so I think that that's
going to be a movie that finally a hit
it's also an Oscar winning film James
Cameron yes he won an Oscar but is he
respected no he's not Martin Scorsese
one of the most respected directors of
all time I would be fascinated to see
what he does with the Smurfs I think he
would get bhabhiji in there he'd get leo
he'd get these huge stars and you know
that's what the Smurfs could use in this
franchise James Cameron is so respected
his IP avatar has its own land at Disney
World now there are no Martin Scorsese
Lancers no gangs of new york land
there's no Goodfellas land even though
that might be interesting if we're
talking IP which is a weird way for
someone to discuss something that would
be artistically pleasing the IP of the
Smurfs is right there it would be
overshadowed by avatar I say IP because
I'm in the biz barely from what you feel
my sister Phyllis and based on those
final arguments what are you saying
great to be back please the AP the
question question is what which
oscar-nominated director should take
over the Smurfs franchise should take
over the Smurfs franchise Joe for the
poem I was dying for the one for the for
the point of the artistic bringing the
actors to it the I'm gonna ko and
everybody what's got our yeah
Joe yeah I'm Tony on one hand that
rolodex that was that I was a that was a
big one but also you know the idea of a
James Cameron Smurf land yeah in the
vein of Avatar is going to be a big draw
to this I'm going to go Cameron so we
have not helped you at all no no no it's
comes unto me and it always should
that's my job here I look in this case
I'm going to take artistic integrity
over commercialism I think we have
enough of it so Wow
Martin Scorsese Smurfs I'm dying to see
Leonardo play what smirk is going to be
I got to give it to Scott Scott when's a
game hi I just got robbed
I didn't say much a better answer I'm
getting I'm gonna be arraigned didn't
give it to you that I will line up the
way we got accepted oh well I got lemon
exception I guess it goes over to you
then I'll take it if he picks Mike not
you
I'll take Scott's gift and give it to
Joe all right now okay well cut up
technically one but no for the record
you want the win to Joe so Joe you are
the winner today's fight alright
[Applause]
oh thank you guys that was a tough feed
round for me leave it there at the end
you really come through the whole show
very impressive and what a show I got to
thank our guests here Joestar as our
winter anything you'd like to plug
look I'm just happy that this whole
Private Ryan thing is why not yeah but
that arc is completed thank you very
much
watch on his trailers and continue to
like online yes thank you they sure
that's my plug I love it thank you Joe
great job I gotta say mr. Scott Aukerman
what are you coming up and I want to
actually plug something I love the
Michael Bolton special Neverland oh
that's really funny
thank you watch that it's not just for
February right to the Ari Emanuel and
let's get you signed you know screen
junkies did it
hashtag yesterday I'm like an re much
better than of the Smash Mouth thing I
agree let's not talk to Smash Mouth
let's make sure let's get you on Twitter
our Emmanuel I don't know maybe I would
really got it
I feel like do you wonder is he just had
an alias and like a joker Melvin travitt
are maybe I am to be pro and buy it and
then you can go in there maybe contact
I'm sure the mayor's office in Chicago
Rahm Emanuel is on Twitter so maybe ask
ROM for his brothers contact
organization talk about no never
happened and Morel over a Twitter yes
Arnold and that's whether I'm not seeing
any official Ari Emanuel a Twitter
account so you may have to go through it
Jeremy Piven on is that close enough
Jeremy says it's wait I notice it that
was given by God let's see I think we do
a lot of damage in this town if you know
what I mean how is every judge Jeremy
Piven for you sure you okay there you go
they give you I per call out yeah I
actually have something plug oh you do
yeah I'm in a movie comes out I guess
looks oh well alright I guess that
yesterday is a Saturday the Jeff Garlin
Netflix movie handsome Wow ruling that
good for you dude are you a kiss on a
roll I am NOT Jeff is of course the
titular you know what I'm saying but I
know what you're saying that's been
Tommy we're talking days here I can get
by on that I doubt if licks now or
what's going on v so yeah what tomorrow
yeah or vote yes
if we plant herbs on YouTube it's
already out we never watch it what's it
called again handsome handsome Oh guys a
lot enjoys you thank you Congrats on
music camp 9 now I know I'm doing this
weekend I hope you all are - thank you
guys so much for watching thank you
Scott Joe Mike what a wonderful weird
episodes that was there definitely some
weirdness in there did not disappoint I
hope you liked - we will be back next
week with another with a regular show so
come back if you didn't like this you
probably too doubt if you didn't if
you're still here thanks for watching
love you have a great week everybody bye
bye